all right it's week two best bets on pro
football talk.com last week MDS went two
and one I was 1 1 & 1 these are picks
against the spread our best three I
guess I got to do better than I did last
week that's for damn sure
this week we're gonna pick three games I
go first this week MDS goes first in the
odd-numbered week so for me we're gonna
start this off with a team that seems to
be falling apart and is throwing a
rookie quarterback to the wolves I'm not
taking the bills I'm taking the team
that is playing the bills the San Diego
Chargers otherwise known as the Los
Angeles chargers - seven and a half I
think this one is going to be ugly in
western New York
Josh Allen was put in mothballs last
week for a reason they wanted to protect
him this week they have no choice they
can't put Nathan Peterman back on the
field against the Chargers team that
picked him off five times in one half
last year I like the Chargers who
probably feeling salty about their
inability to stay close enough to the
Chiefs last week wanting to avoid a slow
start to the season they are going to go
in to Buffalo loaded for bear Anthony
Lin a guy that would coached on that
that staff and maybe feels like he
should have been considered for a head
coaching job there I think he's gonna
have extra motivation to get his team
ready to go and go in there and blow the
bills off the field MDS yeah and that's
not a bad strategy for making your best
bet is find a team you don't believe in
and just pick whoever they're playing
and you know the last couple of years
people made a lot of money betting
against the Browns the Browns were a bad
both straight up and against the spread
and the bills may be the same this year
they may keep losing and keep losing by
significant margins in week one so I
can't pick against the bills
unfortunately but I can't pick a team
that I have quite a bit of confidence
from week one and that's the Chiefs
getting four points against the Steelers
and I really like the fact that I can
take a team that looks real good
in week one and get points with them it
was actually Chiefs were getting five
when I first looked at the spread down
to four now because a lot of people are
thinking like I am and taking the Chiefs
but I loved what
Patrick my Holmes did I loved what I
read still did and I liked the teeth if
they don't win outright which I think
they've got a pretty good chance of
winning I definitely think it or at
least be a very close game yeah and I
agree with you on that when the Chiefs
look great on Sunday at La now it felt
like a Chiefs home game when you saw all
the red in the stands but Patrick Holmes
a special talent I just hit home there's
something about the Steelers that makes
it very hard to pick the upset to pick
the underdog and and it happens it's not
like they win every game at home but I
feel like this early in the season home
opener it's gonna be tough to overcome
the Steeler so I decided to stay away
from that one that wasn't on my list so
I don't feel bad that you took one I was
gonna take now last week you took one
that I thought taking the other side of
would make sense and I didn't you saw
the Buccaneers playing the Saints tough
and I got to give it to you the
Buccaneers win it outright you had the
Buccaneers plus the the big margin they
were getting this week with the Browns
rolling into New Orleans and I don't
want to be anyone going to New Orleans
this week not after what happened last
week I think that Sean Payton is going
to have these guys ready and you throw
on top of it the reunion with Greg
Williams the guy who single-handedly
cost Sean Payton's seven eight million
dollars six years ago the last time Sean
Payton got a chance to go against his
former defensive coordinator the guy who
was the mastermind of the bounty scandal
49 to 21 was the final score and the
Saints weren't even very good the year
that that happened so the Saints giving
nine to the Browns that's a lock this
week I think the Saints are gonna roll
the Browns meanwhile the Browns are just
happy they're not on track to go in 16 I
think that that even they know this week
is going to be a tough one and until
they put Baker Mayfield in a quarterback
I think it's going to be harder and
harder for the Browns to to be the
contender that maybe their defense would
justify them being yeah and you know the
Saints better win because if they were
to lose to the Browns
they would now be Owen sue Oh ensue at
home and Owen to in the two games that
you know on paper before the season
looked like maybe the two easiest games
on their schedule all year so you know
if the Saints are going to be playoff
contenders as they certainly
think they are there about the last name
that it can afford to start Owen - given
how their schedule looks so yeah I tend
to agree with you that was not one that
I was going to pick but I tend to agree
with you that the Saints oughta bounce
back so you've now picked two favorites
to cover and I'm going to pick my second
consecutive underdog
I like the Seahawks getting three and a
half against the Bears now I would say
the Bears overall more impressive in
week one than the Seahawks did until
that late meltdown against the Packers
anyway the Bears looked impressive but I
just have a feeling that the Bears are
going to be reeling a little bit from
the way that meltdown with and that the
Seahawks might be a team that can turn
things around a little bit faster than
people are expecting I mean Seattle is a
very different team they completely
revamped their defense over the
offseason got rid of the older more
expensive players went younger but I
actually think the Seahawks might be
after so many years of being near the
top of the league took a step back last
year I think they now might be a better
team than a lot of people are getting
them credit for and probably a better
team than the Bears and so I like
getting three and a half points when
they take on the Bears on Monday night
yeah and I like that pick a lot and that
was one of the ones on my list of
potential selections primetime game the
Seahawks are used to those types of
platforms and they played the Broncos
very very tough
the Broncos defense was a little bit too
dominant for the Seahawks to erase a
deficit in the final quarter they had
three chances couple of sacks and it
drives an interception at the tail end
of the game which was really a wing and
a prayer that wasn't even close to
getting the Seahawks in position to win
the game but I think against a Bears
team that is dealing with a serious
mental wound after what happened on
Monday or on Sunday night rather in
Green Bay I think that that sets the
stage for the Seahawks oh I agree with
you on that one
all right I feel like you're daring me
to take an underdog and I have an
underdog on my list but the more I think
about this one the better I feel about
the Texans going into Nashville giving
two and a half the
rohde favorite but when you look at what
the Titans went through last weekend in
Miami that's 7 hour marathon injuries to
Delanie Walker and and also the the
status of Marcus Mariota and even if he
can play in the indications are that he
will play he's got an elbow and a
shoulder problem he just doesn't seem to
have the build that is going to allow
him to withstand the pounding of being
an NFL quarterback especially if he's
going to be even remotely mobile as a
quarterback so the Texans still have all
their key players healthy which i think
is a big deal after one week the Texans
I think gave the Patriots I thought they
were gonna win they gave the Patriots a
good enough game that makes me still
believe in the Texans we're not gonna
write them off just because they didn't
go to New England and win I think they
do go to Nashville and win by more than
two and a half points and and kind of
set the tone for the kind of team we're
going to be seeing from the Texans all
year long yeah I agree with you about
that pick I like the Texans this week as
well and I like them to win pretty
comfortably certainly by more than a
field goal so I think they should cover
and I think that's a good pick that you
made my last pick is also going to be a
favorite and I'm kind of following in
the same mold that you went in with your
first pick where I'm picking against the
team team I'm thinking against is the
Detroit Lions I'm picking the 49ers
minus six at home and I just felt like
as I watched the Lions on Monday night I
just felt like mad Patricia's defense
and the players playing on that
Patricia's defense are not on the same
page didn't work right they add the the
picks picks on a very first play of the
game and then after that it just looked
like a mess they were sloppy and
disorganized and I don't know how much
you should blame Matt Patricia how much
you should blame the players but the
fact is I think Jimmy Garoppolo is going
to bounce back from a tough game against
a tough Minnesota's defense and I think
he's going to put on a lot of points on
the board against a much less tough
Detroit Lions defense so I like the
49ers minus six and I think that's
possibly a second straight blowout for
math Patricia
his career in Detroit and I don't know
that any coaches ever on the hot seat
after two games but I do think that it's
going to be real tough for the Lions to
face those questions of players Jim
Caldwell after 9 and 7 the last two
years what are you doing now with Matt
Patricia after no one to start which is
where I think the Lions are going to be
after the 49ers beat them big once the
walls caved in on the Lions on Monday
night did did you notice anything about
Patricia's demeanor on the sideline and
he's a guy who has a much different
image than than the reality I we enjoyed
interviewing him at the Scouting Combine
I had a chance to spend a little time
with him before the interview and he
comes off much different than the the
that that big scraggly beard and the hat
turned backwards and and I just seemed
like he just was disconnected from the
team in the second half and and I just
don't know how this one's gonna go so
you may be on to something but did you
detect that that sense in his demeanor
that I did absolutely on the sidelines
looking kind of confused and kind of
unclear on what was happening running in
front of him and you know I don't want
to too much of a coaches body language
or facial expression in the two seconds
that he's on TV but you're right he
doesn't come across as dumb when when
you see him in interviews talk to him
look at his press conferences and people
who know his background say he's a very
intelligent man but well he looked he
did not look the part of a head coach he
often doesn't look the part of a head
coach you know I'm not going to judge
them on because he has a beard or could
be where the roger goodell clown t-shirt
but he doesn't really have the cool
demeanor on the sideline that you that
you want in a head coach or at least he
didn't appeal to in his first game as a
head coach and that's going to be really
interesting to follow I think you know
like I said I don't want to overreact
he's not going to be on the hot seat for
two games but I think he is one of the
new coaches who you could picture the
wheels falling off pretty fast
and he inherited a nine and 17 with a
franchise quarterback to paying a lot of
money to I think they expect him to be
able to win fast I don't expect him to
go to and 14 and do a total rebuild so I
think it's really one that bears
watching if the Lions get blown out for
the second straight week and I think the
court yeah and and III you may be on the
money with that and and they're really I
don't want to be overly superficial
about what a coach looks like and how it
carries himself but my god that's what
we all look at think about guys like Tom
Landry and and you can't look like an
unmade bed and be an effective NFL head
coach and I'm not saying Matt Patricia
is at that level but just there just was
something there and I think it is a
disconnect from who he really is and I
think he needs to get get an image that
he projects that is closer to who he
really is as a coach and as a person
because it just doesn't come off now
that he's the guy whose front and center
all the time it doesn't come off maybe
the way that he would want it to all
right that's it for this week I this one
doesn't count but I like the Dolphins
getting three against the Jets I really
like this one I almost made it one of my
picks
you almost shamed me into picking an
underdog and I was so close to doing it
but you have any others that you got on
the Shelf that didn't make the final cut
well your pick of Texans - two and a
half that's the morning if you and I
could agree on one I would have agreed
with you on that one we we are not gonna
ever take the same team so I'm not
taking seconds - doing honest but I
really like that big as well as the two
of us were kind of jointly each stone 50
bucks in on a hundred dollar bet on a
team I think we could agree to jointly
billion on detection all right well hey
MDS great as always and we will do this
again next week and hopefully next week
I'll be able to say I had a better week
than you did also all of our picks are
going to be available to Pro Football
Talk comm straight up not against the
spread but you can apply the spread if
you like thanks as always for your time
and we'll do this again next week okay
good talk to you Mike
you